[Music]  what kind of story do you want a really  scary but make sure it has a happy  ending okay tell anyone move  [Music]  someone got down here plane is full or  take his farm away Irina was our home  bed  absolutely not we're not going to lose  our farm why is everybody so afraid of  telling the truth  Danny come over here you know I told you  never to play by that silent  [Music]  no one's supposed to do that I'm here  hey can you keep it leave it  where did he come from he's not one of  us I can't give you anything you want I  can do that anything you want another  world someone wants you to keep a secret  should keep it do you want to keep the  secret Wow there's two kinds of people  in this world and up or then your move  Diddy check me you're going to free it  work you  you know what happened  if we now say each other remember  anything  what happened  [Music]